le pib et les données sur la création
d'emplois ne suffisent plus pour mesurer
le bien-être des québécois c'est ce
qu'affirme le collectif g15 plus c'est
un groupe qui lance une compilation de
51 indicateurs pour mesurer les progrès
économiques environnementaux et sociaux
l'ecosse la nouvelle zélande l'islande
entre autres ont déjà adopté ce type de
portrait statistique pour tenter
d'appuyer les décisions qui auront un
impact sur le bien-être de la population
et ce sont des états qui figure parmi
les modèles du ministère des finances à
ottawa qui veut mettre sur pied une
stratégie nationale sur la qualité de
vie l'économiste françois delorme est au
nombre des experts derrière ces
indicateurs françois delorme bonsoir
oui bonsoir qui a créé ces indicateurs
du bien-être qui est derrière ça
c'est une coalition de gens du milieu
financier du milieu des affaires des
syndicats des ong de la part des
organismes qui sont partisans de la
lutte aux changements climatiques
il ya des manques du corpus académique
ou si on s'est tous mis en jambes et on
a essayé de décider de façon
consensuelle
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait mesurer le
bien-être au québec alors l'idée ici
c'est déjà un accomplissement assez
exceptionnel d'avoir atteint un
consensus étant donné qu'on vient de
milieux très différents mais on y est
arrivé et il n'y a pas eu dissensions
alors c'est un excellent point et on ait
essayé de justement de converger comment
est-ce qu'on peut mesurer le progrès et
le bien-être du québec d'aujourd'hui et
celles en acier 3 et influencer françois
les décisions publiques
mais l'idée c'est ça nous y avions il
avait mentionné tout à l'heure il ya
aussi la nouvelle zélande qui intègrent
ce genre de grille d'indicateurs pour
dire mais il n'y a pas juste la création
d'emplois il ya pas juste la croissance
il ya aussi des des indices ou des
variables de qualité de vie des
considérations environnementales
des préoccupations au niveau des
inégalités mais tout ça ça fait partie
aussi d'une économie ou d'une société en
santé et c'est pour ça que on a
développé 'l'indice de bien-être à
partir de trois piliers un pilier
économique on va oublier social est
oubliée environnemental ce qui regroupe
les composent
alors on va regarder quelques-uns
d'abord dans deux piliers économiques
dont vous parlez vous dites par exemple
de 2015 à 2019 vous mesurer la qualité
des emplois il vous dites donc le nombre
de qualit de nombre d'emplois qualité
faible par exemple abaissé de 13% mais à
qualité moyenne a augmenté de 15% à
qualité élevée à monter de 19% donc
c'est un des indicateurs ça françois
delorme pour mieux mesurer justement le
bien-être de la population
exactement ici langue c'est le marché du
travail s'est pas seulement le taux de
chômage qui doit compter si on n'aime
pas le chômage mais est-ce que les gens
sont satisfaits et est-ce qu'on crée des
emplois de qualité donc ici on prend une
mesure qui dit bon il semble qu à ce
niveau là le bilan soit positif pour le
québec dès 2015 à 2019 alors
répartis dans l'un des indicateurs du du
chantier ou du thème économique dans
l'économique aussi vous avez un autre
indicateur celui là la tendance est
négative le pib dédié aux produits verts
et aux technologies propres sa baisse de
ce côté-là de 2015 à 2019 là le poids du
pib pour les produits verts et les
technologies propres a baissé par
rapport au pib d'exactement alors on
peut penser que nous sommes des sociétés
qui est très engagée dans la transition
écologique mais c'est peut-être vrai
mais d'autres 2015 à 2019 ce n'est pas
le cas donc ce genre de mesure la
gérante nous permet d'avoir une
discussion plus objective sur s'est
arrimé dans des données est ce qu'on a
fait du progrès ou pas donc en général
les indices économiques sont plutôt
favorables mais il ya beaucoup
d'engouement au niveau social et surtout
au niveau environnemental au niveau
social on vient de le voir tendance
positive sur l'intégration économique
immigrant l'écart du taux de chômage
entre la population 25 81 54 ans et le
taux de chômage des immigrants l'écart
baisse françois delaure
exactement donc selon le progrès au
chapitre social le deuxième pilier alors
on voit que la thur on a fait des
progrès sur niveau de l'intégration des
immigrants et
c'est un facteur extrêmement positif
pour
créer ou avoir une société plus
inclusive
il ya également donc le taux
d'inoccupation des logements qui a
baissé donc ça c'est une tendance
négative sur le plan social parce que
c'est rendu complexe se trouver un
logement et on va sur les indicateurs
environnementaux il ya des indicateurs
environnementaux positifs et d'autres
négatifs sur les aires protégées c'est
positif
exactement il une augmentation
significative de déjà protégés d'un
autre côté il ya une augmentation de
giresse donc vous savez c'est comme si
j'ai raconté dans un pilote d'avion il y
en a cinquante et un indicateur 51
cadres et on voit qu'ils ont dit qu'ils
sont ouverts il y en a qui sont à leur
âge et il y en a qui sont au rouge donc
ça nous permet vraiment une vision
beaucoup plus horizontale et sur un
horizon qui puisse porter vers le futur
pour avoir une vraie mesure du progrès
mais on n'arrive pas mais on n'arrive
pas avec un résultat mettre les 51 dans
la moulinette pour arriver à un indice
total
non non c'est la phase 2 du projet où on
va pouvoir comparer québec ontario
canada et on va pouvoir créer des
sous-indices des indices composites
comme on appelle en économie ou un
statistiques au niveau environnemental
social et économique et à la fin on peut
créer ce qu'on appelle l' indice de
bien-être du québec qui va regrouper les
cinq années 50 et indicateurs puisque le
premier né du québec aiment bien se
comparer à l'ontario ce serait
intéressant d'avoir ce type d'indicateur
qui ré justement plus loin que le pib
par habitant merci françois de l'or
merci gérard bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit